[Music]
can anybody hear me there's better days
ahead
death and terror a dramatization about a
global pandemic might feel a little
too close to home
i'm scared me too but as this series
wrapped just before covert 19 took hold
there was little going back
dangerous being profit during times of a
people so its stars hope
audiences will be able to handle the
eerily prescient tone
nothing could have prepared me for 2020.
let's face it i don't think i'm alone in
saying that you know when faced with
un unbelievable um circumstances and
incredible
adversity what would you do you know
what would you fight for
i like that this forces you to to think
about things in that way and i know
after anyone who's been through this
year or can relate
amber heard was in the headlines earlier
this year appearing as a witness in a
high-profile libel case
that her ex-husband johnny depp bought
against the sun newspaper
and which he lost the actress is unable
to speak about it because of another
libel case pending in the states
but hopes her role in this stephen king
adaptation will attract press attention
for the right reasons
[Applause]
i don't want to play characters easy to
understand or whose motivations are
um are transparent it's more interesting
to play a character who's functioning
like many of us are behind several
layers of masks that
change depending on what our situation
is the world is now a blank page
[Music]
the stand is out in january let's hope
that in the new year
life will no longer be stranger than
fiction
you must make your stand claire gregory
sky news